why does your neural network need a
nonlinear activation function turns out
that for your neural network to compute
interesting functions you do need to
take a nonlinear activation function
less you want so just the for prop
equations for the neural network why
don't we just get rid of this get rid of
the function G and set a1 equals Z 1 or
alternatively you could say that G of Z
is equal to Z right sometimes this is
called the linear activation function
maybe a better name for it would be the
identity activation function because it
was just outputs whatever was input for
the purpose of this
what if a2 was just equal to z2 it turns
out if you do this then this model is
just computing Y or Y hat as a linear
function of your input features x2 take
the first two equations if you have that
a1 is equal to z1 is equal to w1 X plus
B and if then a2 is equal to z2 is equal
to W 2 a1 plus B then if you take the
definition of a 1 and plug it in there
you find that a 2 is equal to W 2 times
W 1 X plus B 1 a bit right so this is on
a 1 plus B 2 and so this simplifies to W
2 W 1 X plus W 2 B 1 plus B 2 so this is
just let's call this w prime B prime so
this is just equal to W prime X plus B
Prime
if you were to use linear activation
functions or we go to call them identity
activation functions then the new
network is just outputting a linear
function of the input and we'll talk
about deep networks later neural
networks with many many layers many many
hidden layers and it turns out that if
you use a linear activation function or
alternatively if you don't have an
activation function then no matter how
many layers your neural network has
always doing is just computing a linear
activation function so you might as well
not have any hidden layers some of the
cases that briefly mentioned it turns
out that if you have a linear activation
function here and a sigmoid function
here then this model is no more
expressive than standard logistic
regression without any hidden layer so I
won't bother to prove that but you could
try to do so if you want but to take
home is that a linear hidden layer is
more or less useless because on the
composition of two linear functions is a
sailfin linear function so unless you
throw a non-linearity in there then
you're not computing more interesting
functions even as you go deeper in the
network there is just one place where
you might use a linear activation
function G of Z equals Z
and that's if you are doing machine
learning on a regression problem so if y
is a real number so for example if
you're trying to predict housing prices
so why is a there's not 0 1 but is a
real number you know anywhere from zero
dollars is a price of homes up to
however expensive right how's the scale
I guess maybe houses can be you know
potentially millions of dollars so
however however much houses cost in your
data set but if Y takes on these real
values then it might be ok to have a
linear activation function here so that
your output Y hat is also a real number
going anywhere from minus infinity to
plus infinity but then the hidden units
should not use them your activation
functions they could use value or 10 H
or Li Q value or maybe something else so
the one place you might use a linear
activation function is usually in the
output layer but other than that using a
linear activation function in a hidden
layer except for some very special
circumstances relating to compression
that won't want to talk about using the
linear activation function is extremely
rare oh and of course they're actually
predicting housing prices as you saw in
the week 1 video because housing prices
are all non-negative perhaps even then
you can use a rare loop activation
function so that your outputs Y hat are
all greater than or equal to 0 so I hope
that gives you a sense of why having a
nonlinear activation function is a
critical part of neural networks next
we're going to start to talk about
gradient descent and to do that to set
up discussion for gradient descent in
the next video I want to show you how to
estimate how to compute the slope of the
derivative of individual activation
functions so let's go on to the next
video